hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in chapters 4 5 and 8 of his treatise on
truth saint anselm is going to be
talking about
finding truth and examining and
analyzing truth in you might say
places or domains that we don't
typically
think or talk about truth being in and
those are the will the voluntas and
action axio right in our deeds in the
things that we actually
do and these are going to be very
closely connected
as we're going to see and action itself
is going to be
foundational for
the other kinds of truth that we
have or
perceive or or do
so
he begins by talking about truth in the
will or rather truth of the will veritas
volontatus
and what is this this is not a way that
we're typically
thinking about truth we can talk about a
will maybe being true is in the sense of
like being loyal
but anselm means something more
comprehensive
what is it to have truth in the will and
here he's actually going to take off
from a verse from christian scriptures
specifically from the gospel of john
chapter 8 he says truth itself tells us
that truth is in the will when he says
of the devil he did not stand in the
truth and then he interprets it this way
for it was only due to will that he was
not in the truth or
deserted this truth and the student
responds so i believe for if he always
willed what he ought he would never have
sinned since it was only by sinning that
he deserted the truth he abandoned the
truth and truth was in
or of the devil's will before the devil
did that and we don't have to pick on
the devil necessarily we can think about
human beings we can think about
ourselves when we're choosing willing
loving
desiring things that aren't what we
ought to be
desiring right and so this is you know
quite common and
what is truth in the will well it's a
kind of
rightness or rectitude rectitudo in
anselms latin
and rightness in in what sense well
every will is being you might say
measured against the criteria of
willing
what one
ought quote debit and we don't have to
get too you know worried here about well
how do we find this out or any of those
sort of secondary questions that comes
up in other parts of anselm's treaties
particularly chapter 12 and in his many
other works just assume for the moment
that there is a kind of
built into the universe built into the
fabric of who we are a quote debuted or
what we ought to
be
will choose love
hate desire all the things that the will
does including our habits how it ought
to be shaped so truth exists in the will
when we are willing what it is that we
ought to so like he says if so long as
he wills what he ought which is why he
is given a will so there's there's a
deeper
debit there right a deeper deborah
deeper
what one ought to do the will was given
to us for certain purposes actually a
whole set of purposes as we find out
again through and some other treatises
not just in this very short chapter four
so as long as a person wills what they
ought
which is why they were given a will they
are in rectitude and in truth and when
they will what they ought not to they
deserve rectitude and truth and so truth
can only be understood as rectitude
since both truth and rectitude of will
are nothing other than to will what one
what so that tells us what truth and the
will is
and as we're going to see
there's the truth that happens when we
will what we ought to
and there's also a deeper truth sort of
like the truth in signification or as
we're going to find in action
of what the will is supposed to be for
in the first place
when we turn to the next chapter much
much longer much more detailed truth in
action
again closely connected to willing
because obviously
generally you're going to do what it is
that you will to do i mean there are
possibilities where you do something
other than what you will to do because
of some accident other causes coming
together but in general we're willing
what we
uh
what we choose right what we decide upon
and then we act
so again he'll bring up a scripture
quote and again it's from the gospel of
john truth must also be recognized in
action as the lord says he who does evil
hates the light and he who does the
truth comes into the light now these are
interesting ways again of talking about
truth and you know connecting it with
other things and so he says well what is
this truth in action and
anselm is going to lead his student
through three
identifications so
there's
doing the truth verita
right
is a term that in the narrow sense means
to make to produce
but it can also be used as a much wider
more general term for doing anything in
general and so
doing the truth is going to be the same
thing he says as
doing
well benefactory doing the things that
we ought to do right doing what is
good or what makes things well well for
other people in the world well for us
well in general
and then he goes on and he says it's
also the same thing
as doing or producing
rectitude like detutanem right factory
and so this is a quite an important
thing to say
he says
here we go
to bring about rectitude and to do the
truth are the same it's clear that to do
the truth is to act well and to act well
is to bring about rectitude what could
be more obvious than that the truth of
action
is rectitude and then he brings in a
really important distinction
so
just as with in the earlier chapters
there were two kinds of truth in
signification
there's going to be two sorts of truth
or rectitude
of or in
action and here anselm
is going to talk about
non-rational and rational
action
so
non-rational or it's often translated
irrational although we don't want to get
misled by that it's not action that we
engage in that is irrational it's the
action of
non-irrational things like for example
fire burning or a stone that you throw
falling to the earth or hitting somebody
else in the noggin if they happen to be
standing there at the end of the the ark
or
you know
irrational beings like you know later on
he's going to talk about a horse
desiring to eat its food that's also
non-rational action because a horse is
not rational and it tells us that these
sorts of things are
necessary they happen
by necessity
because that's the way that the universe
is made it's this vast nexus of causes
and effects and you know things lead to
other things it's not necessary that the
horse
eat this particular hay over here
it's not as if that's built into the
fabric of all time and space right but
it is necessary that the horse desire to
eat and if it's there and it's going
it's going to see the hay and it's going
to go over there and eat it so a thing
does
what it ought to do
or even an animal
which are a certain kind of thing
broadly speaking but are sentient and
have desires and
mobility and all that so fire burning is
a perfect example of this a little bit
later on he's going to talk about
iron nails piercing the flesh
of jesus christ when they're hammered in
that's
non-rational action it's not like the
iron says
i need to figure out what i need to do
in this situation on the one hand i am
iron and i do like to pierce things and
go through them because i'm really hard
on the other hand it is you know god
incarnate so maybe i shouldn't do this
the iron doesn't think period
it just does what it does
then we have
non-rational action
sorry rational action
and that is
not necessary in the sense that we could
do otherwise we could also call this to
go back to the will
volitional action because it is things
that we as human beings
in some respect
use our will to choose
it's very interesting to see this is a
bit of a side note how closely connect
connected
rationality
and volition
free volition are for ansem an idea that
is not unique to christianity we find
this also in the stoics for example
to a lesser extent in aristotle and the
aristotelian tradition but
it is really central for anselm as
rational beings
we make free choices
doesn't mean that we can have absolutely
free choices where we like snap our
fingers and the entire universe changes
but we do in fact have some scope of
choice which leads to some scope of
action
and that is measured by whether we do
what we ought to do so when we're doing
what we ought to do we are producing
uh truth in action for example giving
alms now this is an interesting one
because anselm later in chapter 12 is
going to talk about the motive for
giving alms if you're giving alms just
to look like a big shot for what we call
vainglory well that's not really
truth in the will and truth in action in
the full sense but giving alms itself is
something that you're supposed to do
giving alms by the way means giving of
your surplus to those who are in need to
help them out right and that would be a
good example of benefactory benefiting
somebody else
so
he goes on
and he's he's he says that um
every action that does what it ought is
fittingly said to do
the truth
and so
you know fire exhibits truth and
rectitude when it does what it ought to
and we ourselves do that as well
and he goes on and says
this applies not only to actions but
also sometimes to
what what we accept what what happens to
us he says
one who wills what he ought is said to
act rightly and well nor is he excluded
from those who do
the truth right
and so this is is quite important now we
go on and we make another
interesting
set of distinctions in chapter 8. now
why does anselm bring this up
well because
in chapter 7 he has just said well
there's truth in the essence or being of
things
you know all of this depends ultimately
on the supreme truth that's that is god
so in a certain sense everything is
doing as it ought to be or ought to do
and then we can ask the question well
how then can evil actions that shouldn't
exist
exist right evil actions uh come from a
evil will we shouldn't have evil wills
we shouldn't have evil actions right
we can of course
because we're rational creatures and we
can choose between good and evil but
why does god
let there be any of that and anselm says
that
god permits
some people
to do badly
and to do badly because they will badly
mala factory quote mala volunte the
things that they
wrongly badly evilly will they also do
which is bringing
untruth into the world isn't it
so
why does this happen this way and here
we have to think about
the ways in which we can distinguish
actions and one of these is going to be
between the non-rational action and the
rational action so let's look at that
first i've already brought this up a
little bit earlier
so he says that for example
um you know
when when iron nails were driven into
the body of the lord
would you say that the fragile flesh
ought not to be penetrated or that when
penetrated by the sharp steel it ought
not to feel pain and the student says
well that would be against nature and so
anselm then says it can happen an action
or a passion ought to be according to
nature which ought not to be
with respect to the agent or the one
acted upon since the former ought not to
act and the latter ought not to suffer
it so in the case of the roman
soldiers driving the nails into the
flesh of jesus you know his crucifixion
the iron should do what it does the
hammer should do what it does the
person
acting in this case the hammer driver of
the soldier
in a certain sense was doing what he
should do
right he was carrying out a
order given by
uh the governor but he also shouldn't be
doing that and he is therefore in a
certain sense
responsible
and the flesh that the nail is being
driven into which is suffering a passion
it is suffering an action that is
happening coming from another agent
should that flesh not transmit pain
through the body of the person no it
ought to because that's
natural that's what the body does
but this person
least of all deserve to suffer the pain
so there can be depending on how we're
looking at things a
yes it ought to be any know it ought not
to be a truth and a falsity in
actions right
another set of examples getting away
from crucifixion but also involving
violence he talks about a striker and a
struck he says the same thing
ought to be and ought not to be it ought
to be insofar as it could only be
if god allows it to be but it ought not
to be
insofar as it is conceived by an evil
will
he goes on he says there are many ways
in which the same thing receives
contrary appraisals from different
considerations this often happens in
action
striking involves an agent and a patient
so it can be called both an action and
being acted upon now with
both of these the
agent and the
patient the sufferer we can ask
should they be engaging in that action
should they be suffering that action
so he gives a few examples of this here
um
skipping ahead a little bit he says
when
an agent in the thing acted upon or
subject to the same or contrary judgment
the action itself is judged to be the
same or contrary
when the one who strikes rightly strikes
and the one who is struck is rightly
struck as when a sinner is corrected by
one who has the right to do so there is
right on both sides which would mean
there's truth on both sides because on
both sides the blow ought to be struck
it is the opposite
when the just man is struck by a bad man
since the one ought not to strike and
the other ought not to be struck so on
both sides it is not right since on
neither side ought the blow to be struck
but when the sinner is struck by someone
who has not the right to do so then the
one ought to be struck but the other
ought not to strike and the blow both
ought to be and ought not to be right so
there are several different
possibilities
here
and there can be truth and falsity in
the same action at the same time
when we consider it from
differing perspectives so this is a real
important consideration and this makes a
little bit more complicated the picture
of truth and the will and truth and
action that we're seeing and finally we
come to
another key point which is made
at the end of chapter 5.
he says that
in the course of investigating truth
the lord seems to make special mention
of that truth which is in the will when
he talks about the devil i wanted to
consider separately what truth in the
will is
however
when one wills what they ought
and they act rightly and well they're
not excluded from those who do the truth
because willing itself
is a kind of
action
he goes on and he says
since it's clear that the truth of
natural action is one thing and that of
non-natural action another the truth of
speech which we saw above cannot be
separated from it should be placed under
natural action so when
words are doing what they ought to do
even if we're using the words to say
something false
there's still a certain truth in those
words which is analogous to
the fire burning things doing what they
ought to do so for anselm what this
hints at is that action
is actually the larger category of truth
that encompasses
thinking
willing
and communicating so truth in those is
in some respect either analogous to or
even founded on
truth in action analyzing truth in
action allows us to better understand
truth in these other modalities
you